oftentimes when we think about
leadership it's so much about the person
with the microphone or the bullhorn
who's talking so really the most
effective active leadership is listening
my name is Michael Tubbs I'm 27 years
old and I'm the mayor of Stockton
California was this famous proverb that
says if you want to go fast go alone
there's gonna go far go together so I've
learned that every time I've been
effective is because I spent the time to
talk to people listening to people
getting everyone bought in and every
time things haven't gone as well because
I just jumped the gun oftentimes a
narrative around young black men in
particular in stocks is that they're
criminals or bugs or bad etc so I've
spent a lot of time building
relationships and showing people with my
work ethic so I'm not just gonna throw
the idea out there I'll make sure I stop
the well thought out make sure it's
evidence-based best practice and I'll
find two or three other people to agree
before before presenting it and I've
found in doing that they're able to be a
lot more effective because it's hard
when you're young to say we should do
this but of course you have ideas you're
young so always make sure I find other
people with a little more experience
jostles they know what he's saying it's
right it's a good idea
[Music]
one of my cousin's was murdered in
Stockton in 2010 when we had a spike in
homicides so going back home dealing
with the pain and dealing with my own
anger made me really think about what
was the point of going to a school like
Stanford or working at the White House
if it wasn't for doing something to make
my community better I grew up in some of
the more rough parts of Stockton
so growing up the whole measure of
success was leaving so if you stayed and
went to school in stocks and then went
to Community College in Stockton or got
a job in Stockton that means something
was wrong with you like why are you
still here you failed it was only after
I came back and saw it is the impact
I've been able to make with my team to
really make lives better for the people
in our community I realized that success
is not just leaving but oftentimes it's
you could be successful at home you
could leave and then come back and be
successful in that way as well
[Music]
I always tell people I'm only involved
in public service and public office but
I think we do things differently and
better and that there's room for
innovation there's a lot of room to
innovate in government because
oftentimes the government's job is so
that's difficult and you're dealing with
everyone that's hard to think creatively
because I in that comes at risk but I
tell people all the time they're the
risk for me as a failing status quo so
there's something that we could do
that's iteratively better
yeah responsibility not to do it I think
we're in a real moral reckoning right
now and it's gonna take people being
very bold about kind of no I'm gonna
ground everything but we should agree on
like our values and just inherent
dignity that every human being has I
remember growing up in reading history
and saying man what would I have done in
the sixties when I was done in 1860s the
future is looking at us now and I want
to make sure it's very clear where I
stood
I'm a big Hamilton fan so saying we
can't throw away our shot so let's do
everything we can these next four to
eight years understanding we're not
gonna get everything done all the issues
and staunton will be fixed in 48 years
with the least edit path
[Music]